great to me definitely wanted to open up
the world look quite a bit not only from
the narrative standpoint but we wanted
to open it up from a game playing choice
based standpoint so for anyone is very
linear it allowed us to tell some rich
story we want to do that as well but
this time add more choice and more
options to the gameplay so it's an open
world and player can go about accepting
and choosing missions in the order that
they see fit we will leave them through
a narrative missions as well so that
they can get the narrative beats also
we've increased the movement side of
prey to what we call it agile cover
agile combat you can move from cover
points cover point you can hang from
Ledger's shoot over alleges use legends
as covers cover halt use vertical cover
the whole time you're doing that you can
be shooting and the game actually gives
you a little bit of a power boost if you
try and be more John you like from time
to time Exodus is very vertical allows
the player to get to higher ground this
is good number of reasons he can get up
there he can use it as a tactical
advantage he has gadgets where you can
kind of scan the lay of the land and the
combatant said he's going to face so it
gives them a tactical advantage set up
and also during combat or if he needs to
flee you can get up quickly to higher
ground and use that to actually take out
combat the enemies he's looking for
ambien ambien bounties or what we call
bounty Mounties on the bounty wire he
uses that to get enough money and he's
trying to find out what happened to him
right so it's the means to an end is
that it needs to get become more
powerful to do that so he goes to the
takes these on these bounties ambient or
opportunistic or two bounty wire most
wanted list and uses that to
we're trying to find out what what
happened to him how we got here and how
we can get off
you